[Musique]
leur cri résonne à des centaines de
mètres
dans cette région du centre de la Guinée
les chimpanzés s'aventurent désormais de
plus en plus loin
jusqu'au porte des villages
au fil des ans la cohabitation avec les
habitants est devenu de plus en plus
compliquée et parfois les singes
attaquent
[Musique]
cette petite fille de 4 ans accrochée
dans le dos de sa mère fait partie des
dernières victimes
attaquer alors qu'elle jouait dans ce
champ
mon fils m'a appelé pour me dire que le
chimpanzé avait pris notre bébé j'ai
tout de suite crier mon bébé et mon bébé
miaou la bête la finalement relâché
après l'avoir mordu et griffé au visage
je ne sais pas exactement d'où est venu
le chimpanzé mais je l'ai pourchassé
pour récupérer ma fille
une attaque traumatisante pour toute la
communauté alors le village a décidé de
réagir le Conseil des habitants s'est
réuni
et jusqu'à nouvel ordre il a décidé de
ne plus laisser sortir les enfants sans
surveillance
à ne pas
les enfants ont peur d'aller travailler
dans les champs et les cris des
chimpanzés il est terrifié quand on
quitte le village nous sommes obligés de
les enfermer dans nos maisons nous
sommes vraiment mal nos champs nos
animaux et nos enfants sont souvent
attaqués on ne met même plus les enfants
à l'école
on est très inquiet
mais si les chimpanzés attaquent c'est
parce que leur espace de vie se réduit
les champs et les cultures grignotent
toujours plus la forêt
le déboisement s'intensifie il réduit
les habitations sauvages et les sources
de nourriture pour les singes
pour prévenir les conflits des gardes
forestiers seront régulièrement sur
place
leur mission protéger les hommes mais
aussi les chimpanzés qui sont parfois
illégalement abattus
c'est une espèce intégralement protégée
une espèce intégralement protégée on
doit pas le tuer raison pour laquelle
nous sommes là nous te joue entre les
populations et ses animaux là c'est pour
éviter les attaques les confrontations
des confrontations notamment causées par
ces fruits à coque qui pousse
abondamment ici les chimpanzés ont
raffole mais les êtres humains aussi et
ces derniers se sont mis à les récolter
pour les vendre sur les marchés
alors les attaques se poursuivent
et les patrouilleurs n'ont pas les
moyens de les empêcher pour pouvoir
soulever 600 hectares
à pied
on ne pourra pas nous n'avons qu'un GPS
pour combien de personnes
et pour 4 forêts
pour que le conflit entre les habitants
et les chimpanzés s'arrêtent il n'y a
qu'une seule solution selon ce
responsable de la biodiversité régionale
il faut que les hommes rendent la forêt
aux animaux
l'être humain il abandonne les points
d'eau
il abandonne la commercialisation des
fruits sauvages et l'abandonne
l'exploitation illicite des bois qui
constituent l'abri de ces espèces là
donc si ça c'est observé vraiment la
coexistence pacifique sera là sans
problème
pourtant la situation ne semble pas
évoluer dans ce sens
au milieu de la forêt des chimpanzés une
route est aujourd'hui en construction
une nouvelle cicatrice au milieu de leur
habitat historique
[Musique]